so in a moment we'll look at a few
things but before that I want to start
with an actual photo from work we don't
usually do photography at work but I got
special permission to show this picture
the guy in the middle is me I dress up a
little bit differently more formal at
work as you can see and my co-workers
and I are discussing a kind of a common
problem and what we're discussing is
something that has become slow in our
system and if this were not PyCon you
know you would hear somebody say you
know something like this
maybe it's pythons fault but since we're
all pythons does we know that usually
it's not Python it's the world I
actually you know it usually it's not
Python it's it's it's IO bound right and
since it's i/o bound we can solve it
with this great async programming but
when we Google async a lot of times we
find kind of this example being used of
a non-blocking you know an async sleep
which is great but a lot of times the
example is something like this right and
we don't often do this in our line of
work we do it maybe once twice you know
hello world so my name is Ronnie Scheer
and software engineer at gluhwein
bluevine is a fin tech company we love
Python we're hiring so if you'd like to
work with us come and speak to me or one
of my coworker and recently thanks to
our partnership with nationwide we've
been featured in the back of a NASCAR
racer this is absolutely real and the
reason I'm telling you about this is
because I went to high school in the
States and if you went to high school in
the States this is no actually I'm
telling you this because once you're
featured on the back of a NASCAR racer
your app cannot run slow because it's
ironic and so I'm going to talk about
you know kind of optimizing things in a
production environment
and when I say production I mean
somewhere where you expect reliability
so
curity and performance but i think
before we go somewhere that
consequential we should probably start
with something really simple with little
consequence right let's start with time
and let's start with this synchronous
program many of you may have written
something like this with your children
before they kind of ran away and said
never talked to me about coding again
and kind of you know no surprises there
like what would print second not first
what would print here what would be the
second thing to print out you kind of
raised a shout out okay thank you
grading and and what would print maybe
fourth and last okay great and how long
would this take you know given Charlotte
okay so I'll hear about a consensus in
about six seconds it's great keep in
mind this is kind of a bad knot this
laptop it's my bad home laptop so
there's a little bit of overhead but no
surprises and you know this is a live
recording I did not this is not fake
news this is real this is my terminal
okay so no surprises hey - hey for and
just a little over six seconds great now
let's look at that oh wait sleep and if
anybody knows this let's talk this
through so we have these functions that
are async functions and because they're
async we can await co-routines in them
you cannot do it outside an async
function and and basically the code
reads similar to the async code with a
little different at the end you'll see
the main function it uses a really
really handy tool that I'm going to
encourage you to use called ah async IO
gather and what it does is it creates
this extra available object that gives
you a list of the returned values okay
but things don't necessarily wait for
one another so so like
yes you what's gonna print second okay
great great
now what's what's gonna print third okay
what's gonna print last and I like the
money question and how long will this
take four seconds and what does it
dictated by it generally like the
longest great great so you guys know
this I don't know why you're here
no I'm just kidding um okay so let's
take a look at this you know running
great
okay so hate to in two seconds late
didn't wait which is something that used
to be a real pain to do in Python
I used to Google like sleeping
implementations and there are threads
anywhere to die and things like that at
the end you'll see something you're also
handy you'll see the two return values
kind of handed to you by gather so it's
like okay before we go to production we
got to do something with with like
consequence but consequence on myself
and not the clients yet like personal
finance and like all normal people I'm
sure you guys know this I have a CLI a
command-line interface that does my
personal finance for me everybody does
it nowadays it's completely useless
because what are you even doing it's
excreting your portfolio your pension
funds and printing it nice and neat and
smiling and my wife thinks some weird
okay so so you're going over this and
you render the response to the console
one by one and it uses requests how many
of you've used requests in the past how
many of you like absolutely love
requests like really amazing stuff right
and if you told me to stop using
requests tomorrow you're really sad
right so we can't even you know fathom
questioning using it even if it means
like spawning a celery worker that will
spawn like five more because request is
awesome right and not surprisingly it's
not doing too much but it's taking a bit
of time
so we're making these kind of shady API
calls getting the prices of these mutual
funds and it takes about six seconds
right and that's not very acceptable a
lot of times right because we want to
deliver value quickly but since we like
request ly we don't want to switch it
out but what if we kind of like shook
these notions and did something this is
like kind of the naive approach I'm sure
there are people here who can see this
and optimize it even further but just
kind of try to as as kind of without too
much modification like swap this and
here we're using a o HTTP which is
relatively stable
I think safe to say people have been
using it for a while and they kind of
encourage you to use this kind of fetch
put together this fetch function for
yourself which is similar to the way we
make requests right but you get
co-routines instead of like regular
responses right so they don't
necessarily block and the first thing
this is really naive you you have the
core routines collected in this
comprehension and then I'm returning
async I all gather so at the end I'm
returning this big available they'll
give me all the responses and I iterate
them it's like maybe this will take less
time because all the sudden I'm more
dictated by the slowest one let's see
how I do now
so that was that right it's like 0.8
seconds very little effort and like this
is really useful stuff because even if
you have workers that you outsource
these tasks for not to block your
request or your response you don't
necessarily want to burden your workers
right and a lot of times you're doing
this you're collecting information for
your client from multiple api's and now
I'm going to mention the first got you
that I haven't encountered personally
but I've seen interesting warnings about
somebody wrote that they did something
like this and they accidentally
performed a denial
service on one of their partners so so
doing a sync request is very efficient
that's like sometimes you're not used to
this efficient model and you're making
multiple requests and you're actually
burdening servers that are not ready for
this
so I'd say kind of do dry runs right
this is not what we do it work by the
way it's what I do in my free time okay
next I want to talk about SGI it is GI
uh there was I talked about it two years
ago a lot has changed it started off as
a protocol to kind of bring new brought
you know asynchronous paradigms into
Python web applications so we had WSGI
which was this great protocol between
Python servers and frameworks that
allows us to develop more of an
ecosystem and now we have the
asynchronous server gateway interface
which allows asynchronous servers to
talk to asynchronous frameworks and to
kick it off there was Jango channels and
Django and and Daphne and Daphne is an
amazing server I think it's phenomenal
it's very stable and I have not
encountered anything more production
grade than that for WebSockets and
Django channels is incredible and it's
grown tremendously but also since we
have SGI which just dictates the
interaction now we have a little bit of
a great ecosystem showing up so first of
all there's the elephant in the room
which is the django channel django
channels has changed tremendously and it
actually now supports async/await it
didn't when it started out but it ships
with incredible useful tools for
asynchronous code which you'll see in a
second it's great for multiple services
and it does some great things for
containing your code so if you have a
django app you should use django
channels these are some consumers that
you get which do common things like this
is a WebSocket consumer for async away
and there's also HTTP the cool thing is
like you can think of your consumer as a
view so this is like a method
where you're said sending like a chat
message but it doesn't like stopping
this in this send message right because
you can actually run these methods from
other services in a very clean way you
know like all you have to do is
configure your service you know other
service not your process like a command
line or celery task and then you just
get what's called the channel layer and
what it does under the hood is this
method you know message bus where your
services are delivering these messages
and your consumers handle your
connections to your clients and then you
can from another service like this you
can await your channel layer but this is
what happens and get anybody kind of
tell me why this happened to me because
you can only await from an asynchronous
function and it's very likely that your
other services are not async and so what
do we do do we rewrite our entire code
base no actually we have these great
helpers they do what I what I like to
call I think I made this up wrap and
call and so I took this group send that
the channel layer gives me and I wrap it
in an async to sync function from
channels and magic happens and I can
send my message from another service
without having to get dragged into more
async code when it doesn't need to be
and like I think the greatest thing
about this and it's a great compliment
it's like people in my work we're asking
me what are you lecturing about said
like async await in production they said
we have async await in production and
that's huge like the fact that you can
actually contain asynchronous code by
kind of wrapping these functions and by
keeping the service separately so this
Jango channels are a quick thing your
tests also have to be async await and
that can make for some crazy brain
twisted stuff like if you
await a courting you get this co-routine
object that you see on the bottom but it
asserts as truthy so there's a test
that's passing but it's not supposed to
be passing and you can spend day so just
remember even these you know this
communicator is like your test client
and you have to await it your tests now
have to be async/await
and so this is from Andrew Godwin
created order of channels who was here
last year telling us that you know async
capable Django is definitely kept coming
and that's great but we don't all use
Django right what about like tiny
services that we're using right and like
what does this look like the beginning
of what kind of framework anybody I
heard it just say it loud like I well
you can sing it flask okay so so this is
a quart and it's very very similar to
two flasks it doesn't just end there
like this is almost like a flask route
but it's a sink and you can do a sink
stuff with it and as a result a lot of
times you can be even more performant
because you have these non-blocking
requests you can handle more of them and
court also has bindings for some flask
plugins and api's and people are using
it and they're enjoying it I really like
enjoying it for you know my side
spaghetti projects and the cool thing is
that if you can do this you can also
kind of do a while true for persistent
connection right this is a WebSocket
that kind of shoots out the message
hello right but what if you can hold
reference to this WebSocket right then I
could iterate over connections and send
them and basically that means that with
this much code and this is not trimmed
down you know like you can do a little
functional chatroom this is the next
whatsapp and if you're not using it
you're not a millennial okay so
basically
if you're doing a little analytics
engine and you don't want to do a whole
like django app and you want to shoot
things with WebSockets
from your clients like something like
this can kind of be modified to use and
it's great and this actually works like
let's let's take a look this is kind of
me having a chat with myself very
profound like at this point like the dog
is even looking at me weirdly like at
home and this is two browsers talking to
one another through persistent
connections and I think that like it's
very refreshing that you can do this
with this is like with concise small
amounts of code like this is kind of the
dream so basically this is kind of to to
get your appetite going to using these
api's in production I think they're
definitely ready and I think the more we
use them the more useful they'll become
a few things I didn't talk about there
other event loops that you should check
out like Jonathan talked to me yesterday
about this event loop that that's called
UV UV loop that actually can boost your
performance with it's a drop-in
replacement for the async i/o event loop
there are other ones emerging but I
definitely encourage you to try it these
things out and thank you so much
[Music]
[Applause]